these people who hate on people I've
studied them and I've gained a lot of
Knowledge from them because I gain a lot
of knowledge for myself when I was in
that dark place back in the day when I
was sometimes getting bullied or in a
dark place uh sometimes that would have
bothered me how I would want to clap
back I would want to be on there all day
explaining myself to people and how now
I'm in a place now where I can hear it I
can actually know where it's coming from
so I don't just like listen to it and
like make fun of it I actually study it
because I was once that negative person
I was once that person who saw someone
successful and didn't see how could I
get there I was like oh yeah they're
probably cheating or they're probably
doing this I was that negative person
because I wasn't there and I didn't want
to work to get there it's almost like
reflecting an older version of you back
to yourself 100